first and foremost I just saw you and
Johnny taking a picture and I was like
there's miles of jawline in that picture
I don't like
talk
come on now read well Rob Lowe You've
Made Beautiful People and they're
obviously talented what's it been like
for you working on this thing I know you
got to be over the moon this is surreal
I mean this is It's a dream come true to
to be able to work with my son to have
him create something with Victor and I
like this is uh and the way it's being
received that's the thing it was fun to
do we love it but you never know and the
reaction has been more than I ever could
have hoped so typically in Hollywood if
the actors are having fun the audience
will too and boy the first episode is a
blast you are a blast it's a really fun
part I mean it better be I've came up
with it myself but um it's a great
character and it's so fun to be able to
do Lone Star on one side of the equation
and then to come to Netflix and do this
I kind of it's kind of you know what you
can have the best of both worlds
you deserve it you got the Gratitude to
go along with it you know you have the
Gratitude 100 I do and so does Johnny he
really does across his face it screams
gratitude tonight it's a beautiful thing
yeah no I uh we're really fortunate
worked really hard but um tonight it's
paying off it's really fun
so tell me you started your acting
career similar time Johnny is kind of
getting into it do you have any advice
for him how have you helped him along
this journey well I mean he
intrinsically has the most important
thing that I think is
the number one thing actors need to have
which is honesty emotional honesty in
front of the camera you can't fake it
um he's got good comic timing and uh and
hopefully he's picking up some other
good things for me we'll see we'll see
all right so let's fast forward to
success will we season two who's in your
back pocket for a guest star we know
that pratts are close to your family we
got Chad we could get Chad to pop in who
are you hoping for season two guest dog
we've got a a really good long list of
friends I mean when we got Fred Armisen
uh we were we have to we have a a level
now that we have to live up to of Comedy
geniuses
comedy Geniuses only apply for season
two of unstable
all right you deal with your company
deals with Science and Tech if Rob Lowe
could invent anything in the world what
do you invest I would invent a microchip
that I could put in my head so I don't
have to memorize dialogue anymore
that is a well thought out invention
right there and I would love
it's a real everybody could use it like
lawyers giving their closing arguments
would never have to go to it's chat GP
for your brain
are you are you first to go under the
knife for it
I think I might
Rob Lowe doesn't I do it I think I'm
it's a family affair tonight I see your
wife I see the kids is it I mean you're
lit up I could tell but how are you
enjoying it it's amazing I mean to be
supported by my my wife Cheryl and
Matthew my son who by the way has the
only real job in the family
working as a lawyer and then in finance
he's the only one who has like a real
job
um it's great that he that he took the
time out to support this yeah
anytime you can work with your family it
must be a real dream come true I love to
see it man congrats to you we've we've
talked in depth about family and this
moment seems Larger than Life and more
beautiful than you could imagine I'm I'm
gonna savor it for sure
foreign